i think you should yeah  it also distracts the bishop  if recapture happens  from this  diagonal he played g4 i mean that really  is raising the stakes i'm very surprised  at that  yeah likewise because that now  offers a new target for wei yi  do you know what i think he was possibly  concerned about black's queen coming  back to g6  and pinning off diagonal i think that  was the issue actually  um  maybe i could have negotiated that with  a king slide yeah but that's on a dart  square and that's not a comfortable  square  whoa i think that's that's  that's how and why basically but okay  now we've got the pawn on h3  then that's an extra little thing  for  it's over danny he must have lost some  time  wow  he must have lost some time  this is this is just insane